Jetzt kannst du
noch die Füsse hochlagern.
Es ist fast zu hoch oben.
Von mir aus gesehen.
Sven, Morgen.
Und?
- Ja, gut.
Ready?
- Ja.
Wir auch.
Machen wir noch ein Tattoo.
Hast du überlegt,
was ich zeichnen soll?
Ja, einfach einen Stern.
Einen Stern?
- Okay.
Sehr gut.
Ich mache es einfach am Hals.
Ja ... Es ist nicht schlecht.
Ich drücke die Daumen. Während der
Operation geht das natürlich nicht.
Aber geben wir das Beste.
Alles, alles Gute!
Und wir sehen uns sicher später,
wenn du wieder aufwachst. - Ja.
Gut.
- Tipptopp. Bis später.
Also, alles Gute.
- Danke.
Mir wird mit einer Operation
auf der linken Seite
ein langer Einschnitt gemacht.
Ja.
Dann werden 4 cm rausgeschnitten.
Ich werde einen riesigen Verband
am Kopf haben.
Doch, komm!
- Nein, sicher nicht.
In zehn Jahren bin ich 23 Jahre alt.
Ich sehe mich
als selbstständigen Schreiner,
der Autofahren darf -
aber natürlich nur,
wenn alles gutgegangen ist.
Wenn diese Operation
nicht vollständig gelingt,
kann ich
wohl nicht selbstständig leben.
Aber ...
... dafür habe ich es probiert -
zumindest.
Glück und Unglück entscheiden halt,
aber meistens geht es ja gut aus.
Also mache ich mir
keine grossen Gedanken darüber.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
* Wasserrauschen *
Sven ist 14 Jahre alt.
Seit seinem siebten Lebensjahr
leidet er an Epilepsie.
Eine der häufigsten
neurologischen Erkrankungen.
Epileptische Anfälle sind kurzzei-
tige Funktionsstörungen des Gehirns.
Dabei kommt es zu Spontanentladungen
von Nervenzellen.
Die vielen Anfälle
beeinflussen Svens Leben massiv.
Doch es gibt einen Ausweg,
der ihm Hoffnung auf ein neues Leben
bieten kann.
Der beängstigendste Anfall
war wohl der erste,
den ich gesehen habe.
Da wussten wir nicht, was los ist.
Sven war wie ein Zombie,
einfach wie eine leere Hülle.
Als wir ihn ansprachen,
kam keine Antwort, nichts.
Wir dachten: "Irgendetwas
stimmt nicht mit diesem Jungen."
Beim ersten Anfall,
den ich hatte und selbst wahrnahm,
stand einfach alles still für mich.
Einfach alles.
Es war wie ein Foto von ca. 5 Sek.
Plötzlich begann er
wieder zu sprechen.
Ein bisschen wirr. Er versuchte,
Wörter zu bilden. Das ging nicht.
Als er wieder da war,
war er so müde, dass er sich
auf den Boden legte und einschlief.
Am Anfang war es das Ungewisse:
Was ist los?
Wir klärten es ab. Die Ärztin sagte,
es werde nichts angezeigt.
Es sei nichts.
Dann häufte es sich.
Er hyperventilierte,
hatte blaue Lippen.
In einem anderen Fall sprach er
wirr, man verstand ihn nicht.
Er fuhr mit dem Velo
mehrmals in eine Stange.
Wir sagten ihm:
"Hey, kannst du nicht aufpassen?"
Dann klärten wir es erneut ab.
Da zeigte das EG tatsächlich an:
epileptische Anfälle.
Dann begannen die Abklärungen:
Woher? Weshalb?
Es war ein Einschnitt.
Epilepsie kann
unterschiedliche Ursachen haben.
Eine erblich bedingte Veranlagung,
Stoffwechselstörungen,
Entzündungen,
Traumata oder Hirntumore.
In der Schweiz sind ca. 80'000
Menschen von Epilepsie betroffen.
Svens Anfälle
treten v.a. abends auf.
Häufig auch nachts.
Ich merke es nicht,
weil sie in der Nacht auftreten.
Da schlafe ich tief und fest.
Der Anfall beginnt meist damit,
dass er wirr spricht.
* Unverständliche Rufe *
Weil es ihm auf die Sprache schlägt,
hört man, dass er sehr laut wird.
Dann gibt er viel Wirres von sich.
Am Anfang Englisch, am Ende
Französisch oder irgendwie ...
Ich weiss nicht,
vielleicht ist es eine alte Sprache,
die im Oberstübchen gespeichert ist,
keine Ahnung.
* Unverständliche Rufe *
Ein Anfall dauert ca. 2 Min.
Wenn ich aufstehe,
habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
einen Anfall gehabt zu haben.
Sondern eher,
dass diese Nacht schnell vorbei war.
Das sind meine Gefühle
beim Aufwachen.
V.a. die Nächte zehren an mir, weil
wir nicht richtig schlafen können.
Weil wir zwei- bis dreimal pro Nacht
aufwachen.
Wir schlafen nicht richtig tief,
es ist ständig eine
innere Alarmanlage eingeschaltet.
Mein Körper ist total ausgeliefert.
Mein Gehirn
kann nichts mehr steuern,
es ist, wie wenn die Sicherung des
ganzen Körpers rausgeflogen wäre.
Was der Körper vorher machte,
macht er weiter.
Das ist das Gefährliche.
Er sieht in diesem Moment nichts,
er realisiert nichts,
er ist dann - wie du gesagt hast -
wie ein Zombie.
Entsprechend fährt er z.B.
in einen Pfosten, gerät vom Weg ab
oder fährt
über den Fussgängerstreifen.
Er sollte auch nicht alleine
zur Schule gehen.
In der Unterstufe wurde er
immer ein bisschen gehänselt.
Es gab Schüler, die sagten:
"Mit dir stimmt eh etwas nicht."
"Du bist sowieso nicht normal.
Du bist krank im Kopf."
"Mit dir wollen wir
nichts zu tun haben."
Z.T. kamen Aussagen
von kleinen Kindern,
die wohl nicht von ihnen selbst,
sondern von den Eltern stammten.
Ich weiss nicht, ob sie sagten:
"Diese Verantwortung
wollen wir nicht übernehmen,
triff dich nicht mehr mit ihm."
Wenn etwas passiert.
Es gab eine schlimme Zeit. Da sagte
er: "Ich will nicht mehr leben."
"Ich nehme mir jetzt das Leben."
"Ich gehe in den Bach oder schneide
mir mit dem Messer etwas auf."
Dann konnten wir nach Langem
die Schule wechseln.
Dort hatte er das Glück,
einen guten Lehrer zu haben.
Von da an wurde es besser.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
Sven ist ein sehr ruhiger Schüler.
Bei den Sozialkontakten
war er sehr zurückhaltend.
Man merkte es an seiner Sprache:
Er hatte gewisse Defizite.
Er musste manchmal länger überlegen,
bis er etwas sagte.
In Mathe blühte er schneller auf.
Das fiel ihm von Anfang an leicht.
Da staunte ich.
Gerade Kopfrechnen z.B.
lief sehr gut.
Sven?
A durch 100 ...
- A durch 100.
Dann hat man 1 %.
- Hier 1 %.
In der Schule haben wir zum Glück
nie einen schweren Anfall erlebt.
Ganz am Anfang, in der
zweiten oder dritten Schulwoche,
gab er im Unterricht
merkwürdige Töne von sich.
Ich fragte ihn, was los sei.
In dem Moment sackte er zusammen
und wir legten ihn auf den Boden.
Für ihn war nicht klar,
weshalb er auf dem Boden sitzt.
Er hatte das Gefühl,
er sei einfach am Arbeiten gewesen.
Einige Schüler hat das mitgenommen.
Sie haben realisiert: "Oh, das sieht
aber ganz merkwürdig aus."
Aber einen wirklich schweren Anfall
haben wir nie erlebt -
einen epileptischen Anfall
gab es hier nie.
Rund zwei Drittel
der an Epilepsie erkrankten Menschen
können mit Medikamenten
erfolgreich behandelt werden.
Oft gestaltet sich die Suche
nach einem wirksamen Medikament
jedoch schwierig.
Man hat versucht,
die Medikamente einzustellen.
Das ging lange relativ gut.
Aber mit dem Wachstum
und v.a. der Pubertät
nahmen die Anfälle massiv zu.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt hat er
vier bis fünf Anfälle pro Tag.
Es hiess, es bringe nichts,
mehr Medikamente
oder ein anderes zu nehmen.
Lara - Znüni einpacken.
Beim Sprechen braucht er z.T.
100 Anläufe, um etwas zu sagen.
Er kommt immer
bis zum gleichen Teil,
kann es aber nicht fertig machen.
Das wird auch nicht besser.
Ich darf nicht mehr alleine
zur Schule gehen.
Einfach nicht
alleine unterwegs sein.
Velofahren auch nicht mehr alleine.
Aus meiner Sicht
muss dringend etwas getan werden.
Er hat pro Monat
so 30, 40, 50 Anfälle.
Das kann nicht sein.
Svens Anfälle können mit Medi-
kamenten nicht verhindert werden.
Die EPI-Klinik in Zürich bietet in
diesen schwierigen Fällen Hilfe an.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Bitte, so.
Jede Nacht noch Anfälle?
- Ja.
Also ...
Ganz selten mal eine,
zwei Nächte ohne Anfälle.
Und dann sind es oft
auch zwei pro Nacht, ne? - Genau.
Zwei.
Wir hatten schon etwas ausführli-
cher über die Operation gesprochen.
Hast du nochmals -
auch mit deinen Eltern zusammen -
darüber nachgedacht?
- Nein, noch nicht ... so richtig.
"Nicht so richtig"?
- Dass es das Beste wäre, operieren.
Als ich das Wort Operation hörte,
stand ich
dem eigentlich positiv gegenüber.
Da sind einerseits die Risiken
durch die Operation
und andererseits die Risiken,
die durch die Operationsstelle
bedingt sind.
Da müssen wir genau hinschauen,
welche Funktionen da sind.
Eine ganz, ganz seltene
Komplikation,
die aber
theoretisch auftreten könnte,
ist ein kleiner Schlaganfall.
Das kann vorübergehend sein.
Aber wenn ein Gefäss
richtig verletzt würde,
könnte auch eine Lähmung,
ein Schlaganfall zurückbleiben.
Ich habe keine Angst vor
einer körperlichen Einschränkung,
denn ich hatte jetzt
sozusagen auch eine.
Also würde es
mir gar nichts ausmachen.
Die Epilepsie birgt auch ein Risiko.
Die birgt auch ein Risiko
für die Gedächtnisfunktionen.
Wenn das weiter so bleibt
mit den vielen Anfällen,
dann wird irgendwann
das Gedächtnis schlechter,
weil sich die Anfälle immer
in jener Hirnregion abspielen.
Deshalb muss man auch dieses Risiko
der Operation etwas relativieren.
Da haben wir immer ein unmittelbares
Risiko durch den Eingriff,
während die Epilepsie ein Langzeit-
risiko birgt. Das muss man abwägen.
Wenn alles gut passt,
liegen die Chancen, dass man nach
einer Operation anfallsfrei bleibt,
bei 70 %.
Es ist vielleicht etwas befremdend,
wenn man darüber denkt,
dass er aufgeschnitten wird,
der Schädel entfernt wird.
Das gibt mir schon zu denken.
Wenn man nichts macht,
wird es nicht besser.
Es ist ein Risiko.
Ich habe keine Angst an sich.
Es ist einfach ungewiss.
Das Ganze ist ungewiss.
Und alle hoffen,
dass es gut ausgeht.
Die Epilepsie beeinflusst
den Alltag des 14-Jährigen massiv.
Doch es gibt auch Momente,
in denen Sven seine Krankheit
komplett vergessen kann.
Mein sportliches Hobby
ist Rollhockey.
Ich bin im Klub.
Wir trainieren zweimal pro Woche.
Ich bin einfach ...
Ich weiss nicht ...
Eine Sportmaschine.
Ich brauche das, Sport.
Wir nehmen jedes Jahr
an der Schweizermeisterschaft teil.
Die Guten kommen
in die Nationalmannschaft.
Ich möchte
auch gerne dieses Ziel erreichen,
mal an einer Europameisterschaft
mitzuspielen.
Svens Anfälle nehmen stark zu.
Eine Operation erscheint der Familie
nun die beste Chance
auf ein anfallsfreies Leben zu sein.
Bei dir dauerte es
auch schon mal länger.
Wir setzten uns zusammen
und schauten an,
wie es wäre, wenn wir nicht ope-
rieren, mit diesen vielen Anfällen.
Aber es kam von ihm aus, er sagte:
"Doch, ich möchte das gerne."
Für mich ist es ein gutes Gefühl,
selber zu entscheiden.
Und ich bin froh,
dass sie mich entscheiden liessen.
Es hat noch einen Fleischspiess.
Ich habe keine Angst,
freue mich sogar auf die Operation.
Ich möchte einfach unbedingt,
dass es aufhört.
In der EPI-Klinik wird Sven
von seiner Ärztin Judith Kröll
über die bevorstehende Operation
aufgeklärt.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Bist du gut angekommen? - Ja.
Gut,
dann gehen wir mal in dein Zimmer
und erklären dir, was wir morgen
vorhaben - oder übermorgen.
Morgen wird geübt.
Und am Freitag wird's ernst.
Du weisst, dass deine Epilepsie
im linken Schläfenlappen beginnt.
Dann haben wir dir gesagt,
dass der linke Schläfenlappen
auch wichtige Aufgaben hat,
auf die du jeden Tag
angewiesen bist.
Hier habe ich nochmals
aufgeschrieben,
was wir in den MRI-Bildern
deines Gehirns sehen
und wovon wir annehmen,
dass das die Ursache
für deine Epilepsie ist.
Was wir machen möchten, ist,
diese Fehlbildung zu entfernen.
Zwei Drittel vom linken
Schläfenlappen entfernen.
In meiner Vorstellung
löst es eigentlich nicht viel aus,
wenn ich höre,
dass jemand an meinem Hirn operiert.
Ich bin eigentlich sogar froh,
dass es jemanden gibt,
der sich traut, so etwas zu machen.
Wenn es gemacht ist, bin ich
einfach froh, dass es vorbei ist.
Er wünscht die Überweisung
in die neurochirurgische Klinik.
Möchtest du das Kreuzchen
schon setzen? - Ja.
Gut, dann mach's mal hin.
Finde ich toll.
Dann unterschreibst du da -
als Patient.
Jetzt muss die Mama noch unter-
schreiben, da du noch keine 18 bist.
Hast du etwas zum Lernen
mitgebracht? - Ja.
Soll ...
- Aber das ist nicht wichtig.
Die Lehrperson hat gesagt, ich könne
es machen, aber müsse nicht.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
An einem frühen Morgen im August
holen Nadja und Fabrice
ihren Sohn
vom Kinderspital Zürich ab.
Morgen.
- Wir sind da.
Hoi.
Hat es geklappt?
Mhm.
Hast du gut geschlafen?
- Ja.
Es ist einfach normal.
- Normal?
Das ist gut. Darüber bin ich froh.
Der Tag X ist einfach Tag X.
Wir haben vorher
immer darüber gesprochen.
Vielleicht sind wir
etwas hineingewachsen.
Es war nicht so, dass es plötzlich
war: "Oh, jetzt gilt es ernst,
jetzt ist alles schlimm", oder so.
Wir hatten viel Vorlaufzeit.
Wir konnten uns gut vorbereiten.
Für den neurochirurgischen Eingriff
wird Sven ins Universitätsspital
Zürich bestellt.
Sven, hast du dir einen
schönen Traum ausgesucht? - Mhm.
Ja? Welchen?
Vom Grillieren am Wochenende.
- Ja.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
ob da genug Schokolade drin ist,
sonst mache ich dir
noch etwas mehr rein.
Du kannst versuchen,
tief Luft zu holen.
Genau. Und wieder ausatmen.
In der EPI-Klinik
wurde vorgängig präzise abgeklärt,
welches Hirnareal für die epilep-
tischen Anfälle verantwortlich ist
und ob dieses
beim operativen Eingriff
ohne Folgeschäden
entfernt werden kann.
Schweizweit werden
in unterschiedlichen Spitälern
jährlich rund 80 Epilepsie-
chirurgische Eingriffe durchgeführt.
Am Unispital Zürich
schon seit über 80 Jahren.
Wegen der Fortschritte
in der Neurochirurgie
sind sie sehr sicher geworden.
Und dennoch: Jeder Eingriff am Hirn
stellt ein Risiko dar.
Der erfahrene Chirurg
Niklaus Krayenbühl
muss stets abwägen,
wie viel Gewebe er entfernt.
Etwas zu viel - und Sven könnte eine
wichtige Hirnfunktion verlieren.
Das Vertrauen in die Ärzte
muss da sein. - Ja.
Sonst hätten wir
diesen Weg nicht gehen können.
Das Vertrauen in das ganze System,
in ein ganzes Team,
in eine ganze Infrastruktur.
Es muss alles klappen
und zusammenpassen.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Wir waren in der Stadt.
- Einkaufen.
In den Restaurants. - Bei 36 °C
am Mittag in die Stadt Zürich.
Es war super.
- Wir assen Eis, assen zu Mittag.
Haben uns einfach abgelenkt.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Für die Familie
beginnt sicher ein neues Leben -
wenn es den erhofften Erfolg bringt
auf jeden Fall.
Wiedermal nachts durchschlafen.
- Genau.
Über lange Zeit
mussten wir zwei-, drei-,
viermal aufstehen.
Am Ende sogar bis zu siebenmal.
- Genau.
Wenn er seine Anfälle hatte.
Die jüngere Schwester sagte gestern:
"Können wir uns denn
daran gewöhnen, dass jetzt ..."
"Dass es plötzlich ruhig sein wird."
- Ja.
"Das wird sicher merkwürdig."
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Nach dem rund vierstündigen Eingriff
wird Sven noch unter Vollnarkose
zurück ins Kinderspital Zürich
verlegt.
* Sanfte Klavier-
und Streicherklänge *
Hallo, Sven.
- Hoi, Sven.
Geht es dir gut? Hoi.
Mir geht es gut. Und euch?
- Ja, danke.
Geht's gut?
- Ja, ja.
Hast du gegessen?
- Nein.
Gestern Abend konnte er wirklich
nur Hände und Beine bewegen.
Er konnte sich
nicht wirklich mitteilen.
Wir sahen, dass er Schmerzen hatte.
Heute konnte er
zumindest wieder sprechen.
Wir sahen auch, dass er sehen kann,
dass er beobachtet,
dass er wahrnimmt.
Das war
eine grosse Erleichterung.
Denn man wusste zuvor nicht,
ob er würde sprechen können,
was die Folgen sein würden.
Ich bin sehr froh,
ist der gestrige Tag vorbei,
dass die Operation nun abgehakt ist.
Ich bin zwar noch nicht ganz zufrie-
den. Es ist gut, dass es kommt.
Ich bin noch nicht ganz zufrieden,
weil es noch nicht ist wie vorher.
Er ist einfach sehr verzögert.
Wenn man etwas fragt,
dauert es sehr lange.
Oder manchmal
beantwortet er die Fragen gar nicht.
Dann das Verdrehte: Am Mittag
waren die Spaghetti Pommes frites,
die Salzstangen, die er ass,
waren Zündhölzer.
Das gibt mir schon etwas ...
zu denken.
Sven, wie geht's? Gut?
- Mhm.
Hm?
Aber sonst sieht es
eigentlich gut aus.
Es ist auch keine Schwellung
vorhanden.
Mal schauen, was ist das?
Das ist ein ... Pfirsich.
Hm, etwas kleiner.
Aber ähnlich.
Wie ein kleiner Pfirsich.
- Weiss nicht.
Aprikose.
- Die sind aus dem Wallis.
Wie? - Die kommen aus dem Wallis,
das weiss ich.
Ja, die kommen aus dem Wallis.
Stimmt.
Den Namen weiss ich nicht.
- Aprikose.
Aprikose. Also.
Uno spielen ging,
aber das Zusammenrechnen ...
Ja?
Fünf plus zwei.
- Fünf plus zwei?
Fandest du schwierig?
- Sieben.
Ja.
- Ja, jetzt geht's.
Eben, Riesenfortschritt.
Nein, wie gesagt, gewisse
Irritationen sind zu erwarten.
Aber das wird sich geben.
Geht's?
- Sonst melde ich es.
Gut.
Kannst du die Hand
mal neben dem Bett runterhalten?
Man kann an das Weltwunder glauben,
das die Chirurgen vollbracht haben.
Wie sie daran gearbeitet haben.
Ich bin sehr, sehr froh,
dass alles vorbei ist.
Jetzt werde ich
das Ganze auch vergessen können.
Hat geklappt.
Am Freitag oder Samstag darf ich
zum Glück wieder nach Steffisburg.
Dann bin ich endlich wieder
zu Hause, nicht immer nur in Zürich.
Ja, ich freue mich
auch auf den Schulbeginn.
* Langsame, sanfte Klänge *
Bist du froh, dass wir gehen können?
- Ja.
Wir waren elf Tage hier.
Unerwartet lange.
Ja.
Weil das Blutbild nicht stimmte.
Aber jetzt dürfen wir
endlich nach Hause und hoffen,
dass morgen beim Kinderarzt
alles gut aussieht.
Eineinhalb Wochen nach der Operation
bin ich nicht mehr so verwirrt
wie kurz danach.
Ich verwechsle keine Wörter mehr.
Das ist praktisch.
Diese Woche hatte ich keinen Anfall.
Ich wurde anfallsfrei.
Bis jetzt.
Man weiss es nicht, denn
ich nehme noch Medikamente dagegen.
Genau. Sicher nicht so schlimm
wie vorher.
Alles andere stellt sich
in ca. zwei Jahren heraus.
Nach drei Monaten können wir
ein Medikament reduzieren.
Das dauert ca. ein Jahr.
Nach einem Jahr fährt man
noch mit dem zweiten runter.
Haben wir alles?
- Ja.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Es vergehen zwei Wochen, in denen
sich Sven von der Operation erholt.
Schon bald wünscht er sich in einen
möglichst normalen Alltag zurück.
Nach rund anderthalb Monaten
macht er sich wieder
auf den Weg in die Schule.
Säli.
- Hey, Giulia.
Er kommt relativ gerne zur Schule
und wollte nicht zu viel verpassen.
Man musste ihn etwas bremsen
und ihm sagen:
"Komm noch nicht", oder:
"Nimm dir den Nachmittag frei."
Er hat die Klasse
im Detail informiert.
Wie das ging, mit dem Aufschneiden,
was sie probierten,
wie heikel das Ganze ist.
Die Klasse war erstaunt, dass man
von der Narbe kaum etwas sieht.
Die erwarteten jemanden
mit einem Turban und so.
Es ist ja praktisch nicht sichtbar.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
er sei etwas entspannter als vorher.
Vielleicht,
weil die unbewusste Angst davor,
dass er
gleich einen Anfall haben könnte,
es ihn hier erwischen könnte,
weg ist.
Dadurch, dass er
die zu Hause auch nicht hatte,
habe ich das Gefühl,
er sei ausgeschlafener.
Er ist dadurch auch konzentrierter,
ruhiger.
Also ich habe das Gefühl,
das ist ein grosser Mehrwert.
Drei Monate später wird Sven von
der EPI-Klinik erneut aufgeboten.
Ein MRI soll zeigen,
wie die Hirnstrukturen
postoperativ aussehen.
Svens Ärztin lädt die Familie
anschliessend zu einem Gespräch ein.
Guten Tag, Frau Kröll.
- Grüss dich, schön, dich zu sehen.
Guten Tag, Frau Baldensberger.
- Guten Tag, Frau Kröll.
Ich bin gespannt - wie geht's?
Gut.
Läuft alles gut?
- Ja.
Anfälle sind weg?
- Ja, mhm.
Und das erste Unihockey-Turnier
hat auch funktioniert?
Ja.
Super. Das war nämlich
der letzte Kontakt mit der Mama.
Ob du da bereits mitmachen kannst.
Und wie läuft's in der Schule?
In der Schule läuft es gut.
Du bist ganz zufrieden?
- Ja.
Hast du Kopfschmerzen?
- Nein.
Kannst du nachts gut schlafen?
- Ja.
Gehst auch ohne Angst ins Bett?
Erinnerst du dich?
Hier ist rechts, da ist links.
Da sieht man,
wo der linke Schläfenlappen ist.
dass da eine Höhle ist, eine Zyste.
Da ist Gehirnwasser drin.
Das hat Doktor Krayenbühl operiert.
Wir hatten eine Aufbaustörung
der Hirnrinde vermutet.
Man sieht hier am Rand nichts mehr.
Da ist nichts übriggeblieben.
Es sieht danach aus - was man
auf dem Bild erkennen kann -,
dass das
vollständig entfernt worden ist.
Eigentlich das,
was wir uns alle gewünscht haben.
Im September 2019
sehen wir uns wieder.
Spätestens. Okay? Sonst kriege ich
ab und zu eine Mail, wie's dir geht.
Die Narbe schmerzt nicht?
- Nein.
Zeigst du's mir?
So sieht man sie kaum.
Ne, die sieht gut aus.
Sehr schön.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn etwas nicht in Ordnung ist,
höre ich von dir. - Ja.
Wirst aktiv - versprochen?
- Ja. Versprochen.
Toi, toi, toi.
- Danke.
Fröhliche Weihnachten.
- Ja, danke.
Auf Wiedersehen, Frau Kröll.
- Mach's gut.
* Einzelne, sanfte Klänge *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
In den folgenden sechs Monaten
bleibt Sven anfallsfrei.
Die Krankheit scheint besiegt.
Doch dann: An einem Donnerstagmorgen
nach dem Frühstück
fällt Sven plötzlich hin
und erleidet einen grossen Anfall.
Er krampft minutenlang am Boden.
Die Notfallmedikamente helfen nicht.
Die Ambulanz muss gerufen werden.
Es ist der heftigste Anfall,
den die Familie
in all den Jahren miterleben musste.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Nach erneuter Untersuchung
wird ein früh abgesetztes Medikament
in niedriger Dosis
wieder eingeführt.
Zwei Monate später
ist wieder Ruhe eingekehrt.
Sven ist auch heute,
über ein Jahr nach der Operation,
anfallsfrei.
Cyrill, möchtest du so einen?
Seit der Operation hat sich
wirklich sehr viel verändert.
Wir können wieder durchschlafen,
wir sind entspannter,
es herrscht weniger Spannung
in der Familie.
Wir sind wirklich froh,
die Entscheidung zum Eingriff
getroffen zu haben.
"Der Witz vom Onkel Fritz,
er springt über den Kirchenspitz."
"Was hat er gebrochen?
Den Hinternknochen."
"Was hat er verstaucht?
Den Pimmelschlauch."
Das ist der älteste, den ich kenne.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Wir sind auch froh,
dass er eine gewisse
Selbstständigkeit zurückerlangt hat.
Klar, manchmal hat man im Hinter-
kopf: Hm, ist jetzt wirklich Ruhe?
Aber wir sind zuversichtlich,
dass er ins Leben hinausgehen kann,
das für sich aufbauen kann.
Die Entscheidung
war sehr gut für uns. Ja.
* Beschwingte Gitarrenklänge *
Mein grosser Traum ist eigentlich,
ein guter Schreiner zu werden,
selbstständig zu sein
und vielleicht
eine Familie zu haben
und einfach ohne diese Krankheit
zu leben.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020